وهنا الصحافة الإيطالية تقول هاي
منذ أن قال ماكرون أننا كذلك
عار غير مسؤول
غير المسؤول إيمانويل ماكرون
الذين قصفوا ليبيا
لأن إيطاليا تضايقه
كانت له علاقة مميزة على أرض الملعب
مع القذافي
تعريض أنفسنا لفوضى الهجرة فيها
نلتقي
[تصفيق]
المتشائمون إيمانويل ماكرون هم الفرنسيون
أنهم يرسلون lajundormerie لإرسالها مرة أخرى
دعم أي مهاجر يحاول
عبور الحدود في Ventimiglia
ولكن الأهم من ذلك كله
لأنه يجب أن تُقال الأشياء كما هي
يحتاج الى
التقيؤ
ومن تريد الخير
أنت تتقيأ
مقرف ومن يحب فرنسا
الاستمرار في استغلال أفريقيا عن طريق الطباعة
عملة 14 دولة أفريقية يوم
الذي ينطبق السيد راي
جعل الأطفال يعملون في المناجم
استخراج المواد الخام كما يحدث في
النيجر حيث تستخرج فرنسا 30٪
من اليورانيوم الذي تحتاجه
يمشون في محطات الطاقة النووية و 90٪
يعيش بعض الزنوج بدون كهرباء
لا تأتي وتعطي ماكرون دروساً
لأن أفريقيا تهرب منك وهناك
الحل ليس نقل الأفارقة إليها
أوروبا وتحرير إفريقيا من المؤكد
الأوروبيون
نحن لا نقبل الدروس الواضحة